Okay, welcome to another Zoom call.
A lot of questions came in.
Okay, remember to go to the member site for everything.
Do anything you need to know that I think you need to know at least.
Ever you can do coaching calls at any time if you want.
Let's please submit that educational coaching call request form.
And, and same thing with the cheek swab, you're going to do a cheek swab please submit that form online if you can.
That does make it a little bit easier.
And then, remember you have access to all the courses.
And remember I take the product disease and auto the course with the most applicable.
Because you already know everything about stuff.
Cancer course.
All right.
And remember you have access to the blog.
So look on the blog.
There's over 900 blog posts that may answer your question too.
So you don't have to wait.
All right.
I said my lab's in for you to take a look at.
There was a message from late last week over the weekend.
We were on vacation with our daughter's family and did a lot of walking yesterday morning.
I woke up with a tender spot on the front of my shined a hip bone front of my hip bone.
Today, not as sore, but it is a bit inflamed larger than the other side felt great to walk and be active.
So it is kind of strange that is sore up there.
Almost like bummed or bruised yet.
But I did it that he thought.
I could imagine, you know,
just.
It depends on where it is.
So it's.
So what you have to be careful.
If you have metastasis to the bone.
Is you have to be careful of weight bearing exercise.
If it's metastasized to a part of the bone that is a weight buried bone.
And it's a particularly weak part of a body structure.
Then you'd have to be careful.
So that to describe if a person has metastasis to the neck of the femur.
So you've seen a femur bone where they come up because if you are sitting down right now and you put your hands on your knees.
That thigh bone is your femur bone.
It comes up and then angles inward as it attaches with the ball to what's called the acetabulum joint in your pelvis.
Well, that little neck, which it where it takes that angle is the weakest part of the bone.
So in a person fractures their hip.
They have a hip fracture.
As people age.
It is actually because that that neck of the femur fractured because it was weak because of osteoporosis typically.
And that hip fracture now.
If this person who asked this question, if they're paid as way up there, then that's a concern.
The central femur area that's not a concern because the typically, unless you have a great degree of metastasis to the central part of the femur bone.
It's probably the strongest bone in your body.
Not at the neck of the femur, but the central part of the shaft of the femur bone is the dead system strongest part of the body.
And the last pet scan.
It was a recent pet scan and there was no metastasis to the femur, the neck of the femur whatsoever or the pelvis.
Then I wouldn't be concerned. Now you can't have referred pain from bone.
You can get deep bone pain, but you can also get referred pain to what's called the dermatome, which is the skin surrounding the area.
And it will be a neurological referral that as a tabular area, the neck of the femur is iterated by, I think, L3, maybe L3 or L2.
That's your third or second lung bar.
And the front of the thigh is iterated by L4.
Certainly, if you had the metastasis to the lumbar spine and walking, because you're doing this weight barrier exercise and you're walking.
If it was irritated, if you have, if you have a metastasis to L2, L3, or L4, it could refer pain along that dermatome, so you could have, it could be referred pain is what I'm saying.
So, yes, when you have cancer, we tend to think everything is related to the cancer.
But, and that is not true, but it should be, no, we don't want to be worried, so it should be your first go to that, is this referred pain from metastasis to the bone.
And the only way to really rule that out is to look at a pet scan, or a CT scan of the bold, if that was done recently, an x-ray of the bold is much less invasive, but it's, you're not going to see,
the boldie destruction of tellers, at least 50% bold destruction of an x-ray, where you'll see that much earlier on a CT scan in the earliest on a pet scan.
Do you recommend finding a stool test that will tell you the bacterial composition of your gut, so you could tweak your diet that way.
Great claims, as well as Genova have a real good stool sample test, you can get that through our partner rupa labs on our, you can see it on the member site.
But no, I don't, I wouldn't really say that, I wouldn't really go off of my bacterial balance, beating my flora, beating my microbiota.
I would not look at a stool sample test for microbiota, and change my, my probiotic to try to adjust that or change my diet to try to adjust that, because your microbiota change is daily, based upon what you eat.
So I don't think it would be accurate long term. Now, if the caveat to that would be, if you're having major stool problems, you're having diarrhea that you can't get, you know, get rid of, you're dealing with, you suspect parasitic, got parasitic issues that you just can't keep in balance, then that's really what the stool test is for.
No, I know there's functional doctors that are pushing this stool test in order to look at your microbiota and give you a different probiotic and such.
I just, I just don't think that's very accurate simply because your microbiota changes so quickly.
If you went and stayed on a vacation and you're on a vacation for a week and you ate differently on that vacation, your gut microbiota changes, I mean it literally changes daily.
And that's a big reason why you, I think a lot of people would say if they go on a vacation, they can end up with a little constipation and stuff.
But it's why is that because you're eating out, you're eating differently, your lifestyle is differently, and it changes because of that.
My thyroid test results indicate poor T4 conversion, but my antibodies are okay, any ideas, could my intermittent fasting be driving T4 to reverse T3.
So here's the tests, we'll get to this question here in a second.
TSH is barely in range, maybe it's actually low, free T4 is high in the range, reverse T3 is out of range.
So if you looked at the autoimmune course and there's a whole section in the autoimmune course on thyroid, so make sure you go and spend a little bit of time on that.
If your thyroid secretes thyroid hormone, mainly 97% is in T4, 5 to 10% is in the active form of T3, and then T4 is converted to T3 in the gut end of the liver.
And this person is asking, why is my T4 getting converted to reverse T3?
If your T4 gets converted to reverse T3, then that reverse T3 is an active, and it can never become an active again, so it becomes useless.
That's called conversion defect here, you have an under conversion, so T4 is converting to reverse T3 instead of active T3.
And that's an issue, but that could be a problem. Well, that's a gut issue, a liver issue, is the possibility, the question is, could my intermittent fasting be driving T4 to T3 to reverse T3?
I don't know, I've never seen any literature on that, I've never, I have not seen any studies on that, I don't think they exist, so I'm not sure about that.
Your TPO and Thyroglobulin antibodies are normal, that's good, that means you don't have Hashimoto's, so that's great, but your T3 is barely in range on the low side because you have that poor conversion.
So, what do you do about this?
This may be the same person that asked this question about the gut, this may be a reason to do a gut test because you could have parasites that could be causing that, it's a possibility that H-Pylori could cause that, that's just my suspect.
And that's the case, got parasite test, won't test for H-Pylori, but you could rule out parasites by doing a gut test.
Copper is out of range and low, that's 78, that goes to what does low copper indicate to you. Well, if you didn't have cancer, you maybe want to supplement a little bit of copper, but somebody that has cancer, you'd like to keep a low copper level.
So, with the cancer diagnosis, I'd say, you just keep a low copper level, that's a good thing.
But with the rest of this question, you may want to investigate if you have parasites that's causing that conversion issue.
Personally, I would just start taking some burberry, because that will help kill any H-Pylori, and that can help kill some parasites.
I would spend my money on just taking through supplements, maybe by a bottle of the armpire clear or something like that, or just get some burberry and use some burberry to help kill H-Pylori.
And then maybe retest the symptom, sure you're clever, retesting any kind.
Is that one cancer marker P-test that I was doing back again? So, I think this person is talking about the test that you said to the Philippines, and I don't know.
Maybe somebody could chime in. I don't know if that is back line again, if we could do that again.
I know, as I think the last time anybody chimed in on that was about three or four months ago, so I'm not sure.
Whoever asks this question can certainly reach out to them via email, whether that's available.
I would like to do the 21 day fast again under your guidance, since doing it last time I've gained 40 pounds and it's been awful.
I want to be under guidance to know if it's a good thing for my body right now, or if sometimes it isn't good.
I want to fast track my healing, it felt a lot happened and shrunk what I did. And afterwards I crashed as my body went into their syndrome.
Again, I talked about this a lot. I'm not in favor of doing along fast with cancer.
It does increase IGF-1 levels, which can increase cancer growth. Now, I know that there's probably people on here that have, you know, did a 10 day faster, five day faster, whatever.
And they did just fine with it. So, if you feel led to do that, then by all means do that.
I can't really be your guide. You need a local guide to help you with that. That's measuring your way to and getting regular blood tests. You should get a good governor to make sure you don't go into
a new coast situation. And you do need guidance, but really at a distance it's hard to guide you. So you really want a local practitioner to guide you on that.
And it's not something I would recommend. So I wouldn't really go comfortable guiding.
Yesterday, I learned that the chemo was supposed to start tomorrow. The carbon plant is unavailable due to a nationwide shortage. Instead, they're switching me to something called doxel.
Would a switch and chemo like this also required adjustment in the supplements. No, I'd say no, I wouldn't do that.
I've popped in there. If I test IDF one, what is a good test? What is a good result for cancer patients? So IDF one has a range. So you can follow the range that the lab gives you. I can't remember it.
Under 270 or something like that.
I had neck cancer with tumors and symptoms all on my left side.
It's not really a question. So if you want to reformer like that question.
I was having an incredible bone pain in my shins similar to pain I had during chemo. I went off the laminate.
Laminate is a supplement for two days of the pain stopped. So does this need it was a herximer reaction and is not concerning.
And should therefore resume the supplement.
I would not say that shin pain is a herximer reaction.
I mean, baby somebody would say that I'd say show me the metabolic pathway. I mean, I'm just trying to figure out in my mind reading this question what the metabolic pathway would be.
Now, I'm not, you know, I've stated before about a giant fan of just taking the lambating.
It doesn't test well for you, but I just think of the pathway.
It's certainly I can't imagine a pathway.
So by definition, a herximer reaction is when you are killing off things in your body. So you're producing what's called an endotoxin.
And most commonly seen when you're killing off gram negative bacteria, because gram negative bacteria in the cell membrane have lipo polysaccharides, which are large and stimulated immune response are difficult for your liver phase one and phase two pathways to get rid of they circulate a lot and you can get sick.
You feel ill, you can feel off the tea, you can feel like flu-ish.
That's because you're producing a lot of endotoxins.
I can't for the life of me, maybe it'll come to me, but I can't for the life of me. So I think that pain or the shin would have anything to do with that whatsoever.
Chins are integrated by your fourth lumbar nerve.
I, I don't know if I would say that I would be able to stay off of it.
Would buy the bigger right bulb like the double bubble, who X2 double bubble, increase the likelihood that will get rid of the cancer. No, it would not say that.
The double bubble really is only really stronger than the hammer tube. If you put the double bubble right on you, if you're, the double bubbles made to sit away from you like you're working in the kitchen or something like that, then you might be getting.
But now with the, with the jackhammer, you don't need any other bulb. I mean, if you wanted to work in the kitchen, have your bulb on and you're walking five feet away from it, then you walk up next to it and then you walk three feet away and you're doing something like that, just get the hammer, the jackhammer connection.
There really isn't any reason to buy the QX2 double bubble at all. Can you address fasting before chemo? What is the benefit? I have a friend with breast cancer who does a 500 calorie a day, die at the day before chemo and chemo day and the day after.
That's a good approach. So yes, that is a very good approach. I talked about that in the in my blog post on chemo protocol. So that's what what I'd recommend, you know, everybody do fast, do a 24 hour fast, the day before you do the chemo. And I think you could just start eating right after the chemo.
So the chemo, the idea, but if you think of it like a cartoon, the chemo cancer is, is very metabolically active. So like a cartoon. It's very hungry. So it's like gobbling up things around, we just devour everything. But if you like garment the day before the chemo, it's going to be really hungry. You can think of it that way. It's going to be super hungry. And then you pump chemo into your system, it could gobble up the chemo.
Now, the studies that are out there were done by, I think, oncologist email oncologist, I heard her speak once and met her at a seminar a few years back.
I think out of the University of Southern California school of medicine.
And she did this with she actually had a patient that fastened before chemo and did and decreased her symptoms of chemo by about 50% so she started doing this with her patients, having them fast before chemo and she, she saw a 50% decrease in symptoms.
Now, I don't know if you can really measure if the chemo worked better because your control group. I mean, everybody's so different with chemo, you can't, you know, really measure it that well, but there are some studies out there, you can Google some studies on fasting before chemo.
I would suggest a 24 or fast before chemo. Often when I try to start a new program on my right, it will say that I must stop the program. It's currently ready before beginning another one, however, there will be nothing to show that the program is actually running the bulb is dark billboards or time or running below, et cetera.
And nothing happens when I push stop, the only override if follow is that to totally shut down both the right and laptop and started over each time.
Okay, so remember when you do to the right, I highly suggest you look at the member site, the right page on the member site and we can go through the right course.
Because the use of the right is the way I suggest you use the right to get run on your program and you close your computer that will most likely be the fix because you're getting feedback. So these right is putting out these frequencies. Well, these frequencies, you know,
aren't good for your program itself. Once you hit run on the right, it sends the program, once you had run on the computer, it sends the program right to the right machine, you literally can turn off the computer, you can unplug it, you can throw the computer out the window, the program is going to run till it's done.
So it's the program has been sent to your F122 right machine. So you don't need the computer anymore, so close the computer. Therefore, you won't be getting the feedback because the computer will go to sleep or turn the computer off.
So the computer goes as completely shut off. Well, that will typically be the fix to this. And when you get this, like the error message, the USB error message is another one you get it's because you're getting feedback to the machine. It's just wonky with the computer.
When my genetic testing comes back, will I receive results via email? Yes. Is there a clarified coaching call that goes with it? No, but you can schedule one. So you can schedule, you can schedule to talk to me anytime you want versus to feed of that. So that's why we do these Zoom calls so you don't have to do that.
And that's, and you also have access to the read your genes course. So with the genetic.
When the genetics come back, you're going to get the full report, which is like 250 pages and drinking like drinking from a fire hose.
Most people are going to look at that. So I actually put together a genetic summary report. So you'll also get this genetic summary with just the genes highlighted that you really, I think, are concerned. So most people just look at that.
And then you also get the genetic, the full genetic reports about 250 pages, the genetic summary reports about 17, 18 pages, and I also give you a genetic action step report, which is like three pages.
So just some dietary things to change, and then some some supplement things that I want to change.
I just didn't want today for somebody that I didn't make any supplement changes. So, but usually there might be one or two things that we might add or change on your supplements based on your genetics.
Because I've been on so many supplements, you requested that I let you know as I run out so you can advise me on whether to quit or to continue one.
And how would you like to share that said it to info at colors clinic.com or you can send it to labs at colors clinic.
I'm curious why does immuno therapy have side effects if it's just supposed to boost your immune system because that's not what immuno therapy does kind of misleading.
Immuno therapy is a drug. So I've done one, keep through the IVs can it keep you awake, can it keep you awake? I don't know about that. Every drug has side effects. So the immuno therapy what immuno therapy does what we talk about immuno therapy, we're talking about the medical definition of immuno therapy, which is a drug.
So one of the reasons why your body doesn't kill every cancer cell is that your cancer cells are your own cells and your own cells will have a little receptor on it that attaches to a killer cell killer T cell to tell the killer T cell that hey, I'm self tissue don't kill me.
And that's the way your body keeps your immune system from killing all your cells because if you didn't have that then your immune system would just be you'd be dead because you kill yourself your immune system would kill you.
So somebody got the bright idea is hey if we could create a drug that would actually block that receptor so it would fool your killer T cells.
And your killer T cells will kill self tissue that it will kill you know the cancer well make sense to me, well the problem is it's not specific to the cancer so it's not going to just attach to the receptors on the cancer cells it's going to attach to all the receptors.
So you are definitely going to get side effects from immuno therapy the number one side effect on immuno therapy is a is an auto immune disease because you're you're you're killing self tissue and you can actually create antibodies to that self tissue now understand you will always create antibodies to that self tissue so the the kind of you can end up with kind of a temporary auto view disease so you should have been told by your oncologist that if you're going to do immuno therapy.
You can get anything any disease disorder that ends in anitis so like colitis that's inflammation of the colon so you know you can get bio carditis that's inflammation of the hearts the heart you can get anything that's causing inflammation of the body because you're getting destruction of self tissue.
You hopefully to the cancer but you can get it anywhere so this is a drug and it also has other side effects so you can Google the side effects of Petruda and you'll see that maybe keeping you awake is one of the might also so i'm still on a feed to miss or anything that can help with the inflammation and tightness in my throat so I can.
or quickly recover and swallow it i'm working with a therapist speech that's all it is to well anything nutritionally that will decrease inflammation.
Is really your best bet um which we described multiple times all the flavonoids the curcumin resveratrol the green tea extract the as well the white willow mark the stinging nettles the.
corset them those are things that will decrease inflammation anywhere in the brain and the body any type of inflammation you have that's probably your first go to from your traditional step looks like i'm going to be having a pet scan in the next week or two are there things I should be doing taking to protect myself before or after.
well pet scan does include radiation so maybe the radiation holiopath would be in order or you can find that on our store it's a holiopath that we make.
um and you spot all the instructions on that bottle now whether you're going to do CT scans or.
Our pet scans or radiation therapy using that radiation holiopath this goes through the whole bottle of it whether you just did a pet scan in the whole bottle.
The last about four months baby five months i don't know um there's a lot of drops in a little dropper bottle we're only taking like six drops a day so to last you a while.
If you did radiation therapy you should probably go through a couple bottles of it and nothing is going to pull out radiation from radiation therapy it's just going to be.
there are any tests and the insulated radiation the chemo is there any danger for me to be around others we have a brand new grandchild and very elderly parents.
Well this is a good question i don't think anybody's asked this question before um now if you ask your oncologist this question they probably say no absolutely not you're fine.
But the truth is if you're doing radiation you know is there a radio activity that is that could shed.
If you're doing chemo ivies is there chemo therapy uh is that is that something that could that drug could that be shedding.
Now again if you ask anybody in the medical field they'd say no that's nonsense but um we're smarter than that the truth is.
Yes that's that probably could take place um now the shedding of a chemical from chemo probably have you know some sort it's going to be have some sort of half life um and chemo really doesn't work within 48 hours and it dissipates fairly quickly after that especially if you're working on trying to detox it.
Um if you're exchanging bodily fluids that's going to be even worse so i'd be careful on how if you have a new grandchild i'd be i wouldn't you know i'd be careful how close you get to the new grandchild or the elderly parent.
And um making sure that you're not exchanging any bodily fluid like kissing and having saliva exchange yeah there's there's risk in that.
We saw that with this last vaccine with the mRNA shedding that was real that's a real thing and don't anybody tell you that it's not because that that can happen so i would be careful uh yes i would be careful.
I can't uh i don't know if you can look at the study that i know there's some studies on shedding with the mRNA vaccine that you could dig up um but i i don't think i don't know what if there's any.
studies there may be some studies on radiation i don't think there's any studies on chemo um but yeah that is a real thing.
Where are the website are the instructions for the easy-peasy coffee edema.
Oh well let's look right now all right sorry so it's on the detoxification details page so on the member site
it's not on the website so go to the member site it's on the detoxification details site right it's in also several of the courses it's in the
definitely in the seven basic detox course multiple pages but on the member site it's on the page it says detoxification details uh and where is the
information about the automobile sirex panel so sirex is spelled at the c sirex panel that it's called array 10
um that is there's tons of information about that under the automobile course um there's really got a lot
of information on that if any of the um the member site um but on the automobile course there's a ton of
information on that and you can get that if you click on the member site you click on the labs and go to
our lab portal this group of health then you can order that array 10 panel so if you want information
i've actually created numerous videos on why you test for foods and and and everything on the automobile course
one of your teachings articles you say that radiation will shrink tumors but doesn't actually kill cancer
since it doesn't kill the stem cells so let's clarify that well it can't it will kill cancer so the
only way you could shrink a tumor is by killing the cancer is it going to ultimately solve the
person's problem if that's the only thing that they did no nor will chemo because chemo and radiation
don't kill cancer stem cells well radiation won't kill cancer stem cells if they're right at the area
that you're you're radiating because it'll kill everything um but cancer stem cells are all over your
body and trying to set up home and raise a family so you have to be doing other things too which
you are um which even a lot of people that you know aren't even quote unquote doing alternative things
are their body is trying to kill cancer stem cells so but you can't expect radiation to chemo to kill
cancer stem cells if anybody said that they think they're for the purpose of killing cancer stem cells
they're lying to you because it's just not true it doesn't so you have to do other things to kill
the stem cells i was recently i was told recently by an ecologist though that radiation does completely
kill stem cells and so is active curiously well yeah if you if you hit the whatever cells you hit
with radiation they'll kill them whether they're your normal healthy cells whether they're
cancer cells or whether they're cancer stem cells or other stem cells in your body it'll kill anything
that you're pointing it to um but you're only you're you're point you're not doing full body radiation
you know if you were going to try to kill all the stem cells in your body with radiation
you would die i mean you can't it's impossible without killing the patient so for an ecologist to say
that that's that's really it's very very incorrect information um now i get she's just trying to say
oh this is going to cure you but still for that that is just that's not that's not honest either
i still get why these guys could say anything they don't want please the ability to follow
i've been getting red welts on my legs torso hips and arms since mid-January they can be
weirdly straight lines that often look like dog scratches or red cone trails there is no pain
and little itching and they come and go without warning stayed only a few hours i think i can't find
no causative factor for what i eat to take or do is this a side of detoxing well it can't actually be
a side of the line visits so um and other tick-borne illnesses so i don't know who was to ask this
question but it might be a good idea to do a line test that's uh the uh the uh the uh uh the
rupa uh lab on our labs and i know it's like four or fifty bucks but it might be in your best
interest to do that i purchased the holiopathic liquid or a pet scans that's the radiation holiopath
it says it's three drops twice a day tomorrow at seven a.m i have a pet scan and you can
and do i continue this holiopath tomorrow also yeah so i guess i already answered this question you
finish the bottle so just go through just keep taking it every day until it's done the plurdumo
could not tell me anything uh any more than the regular MRI i had after talking with their
radiologist so had no chance but to do the pet scan okay with the coffee edibles i do this about 10
thirty eleven a.m. daily i take my supplements and smoothie about eight a.m. when i do these
coffee edibles at 10 thirty does this delete all my supplements no no both your five at that time
i gf1 was 103 in a range of 60 to two oh seven so it's okay as long as it's not high at all the
yes yes i know we need i gf1 or maybe so maybe i'd be able to drive it alone right oh i wouldn't say
you're driving alone you just don't want to do things that spike it so i don't i don't i don't think
the purpose is to lower your i gf1 the purpose is to don't do things that will spike i gf1 you don't go
to take growth hormone pills you don't roll and do things that will stimulate i gf1
which are a lot of things in the in the exercise in the in the anti-aging field um you know our
things to stimulate i gf1 stimulate growth hormone because if you have growth hormone you you know
you're gonna produce more cells you're gonna you're gonna you know you're you're gonna be able to
recover from workout easier you're gonna be able to do more workouts and you'll have the health benefits
of that well we know what to do that when you have cancer so i have been sleeping with the right
for only about two and a half weeks when i had in the foot bath and the day frequencies i started feeling
overwhelmed with blurry eyes, brain fog, headache, etc plus the tumors my right breasts seem to be
getting larger as it makes sense that i would feel worse before i feel better no it doesn't i've never
ever had anybody say that they have blurry eyes and brain fog and headache that they're doing the right
or what are something else is going on who know that doesn't make sense no a person could feel worse
before they get better in different ways but not with blurry eyes not with these symptoms we're talking
about um we may want to chat that's huge on i've had head and neck cancer with tumors and symptoms all
on my left side since January my prodigland gives sharp pain what i begin to eat
but then it goes away the last few days it continues to fire while i eat and it won't go away the
pain is intense do you have any ideas on anything that would help this um i want to say if i were you
i'd run the day programs with a bulb right up by my face if i were you that's what i would be doing
definitely drink you lots of water try that that will help flush out your glands better than anything
um supporting your detox pathways as best your kid doing will talk to you and it was if you had to
do it uh uh pastoral packs or just heat packs over your liver would be helpful those are the things
that i would be concentrating on when i lie down and my head is on the pillow i feel light headed
and feel like i'm moving can this be fired or red blood cell deficiency uh it certainly can be a
debia so getting a cbc would be in order just to test for that um the uh that would be
every number one number two would be uh blood sugar issues so if you just have a glucometer at home
make sure you testate your blood glucose levels to make sure you don't have hypoglycemia
um um those would be the two biggies that i would look for so get that going and let's see what's
going on what's happening everything you can happen if you got it you know yeah if it's truly dizzy
and you feel like you're spitting you can have um a uh issues issue with your with your
inner canals in your ear that could be an issue too but it doesn't sound like you're spitting
but doing regular fast walking some running light weights lunges pushups just to get my limb going
that will increase my IGF too much right so no exercise itself isn't really going to increase your
IGF i'm talking about people taking like these exercise supplements that's what you don't want
to be doing um even uh nitric oxide supplements you shouldn't be taking those okay nobody is on them
because unless you're taking them without asking me um uh but uh as i if you were taking them i took
you off of them that will stimulate bedjet production will stimulate IGF one that fasted over 24
hours long just to stimulate my IGF one two can you explain why soy is good or bad for breast cancer
so soy and soy iso flavonoid label labelones um are estrogenic that's why they're bad so even if
it's organic soy the only difference is if it's fermented soy so fermented soy is totally different
that's what highland is so highland is a fermented soy supplement that uh acts completely different
than soy so if it's fermented it actually can dislodge bad estrogens from estrogen beta receptors
if it's not or that did that it can actually block estrogen beta receptors and estrogen beta
receptors are apoptotic receptors on the cell membranes of illicit cells also has been definitely
on cancer cells again blocked so soy is i would say soy shouldn't be used by anybody period whether
you have cancer or not soy is not a good thing to be eating that if i the vast majority of soy
grown in the United States and it could be purchased that it states it's all GMO so it's another reason
why not to be using soy but even organic non GMO soy is going to be estrogenic and you we do not
need anymore um zero estrogens in our body we're you know we're having all sorts of estrogenic
issues because of that so um that should be a no no to everybody male or female whether you have
cancer or not should not be consuming a lot of soy i didn't even think of the holyopathic drops while
totally is doing radiation um it's been a month since you finished it when it's still helped
you'll absolutely so you still have radiation in your body the more you can get out of there
when better off it'll be on my genetic test you stated to avoid kale i have the greens that has
fermented kale and combo with other greens would this be okay to take if it'd be fermented yeah
what when you want to the reason why you want to avoid kale as a cancer patient it goes back to this
side you have one question because kale is kale is a great product because it stimulates nitric
oxide synthase so nitric oxide synthase is fantastic for your cardiovascular system helping you grow
new vessels helping for your heart so you want that you don't have cancer so kale is a great thing to
eat it's got more nitric oxide in it than any other plant product any other food product you know it's
got three to four times more nitric oxide than spinach which is the next virus but nitric oxide synthase
increases that Jeff which is vascular and we have to go growth factor which increases vascularization
of tumors so we don't want to stimulate that too much however you need nitric oxide your body so
it'll get me wrong um so but you just don't want to be doing kale shakes and stuff so if your
if your greens has a lot of kale in it then maybe you want to switch to something else certainly
if you had a little kale in your salad or something because it was in your salad mix that's just
if you you know if you're making you know your purpose they buying kale at the grocery store
juicing it or putting it in your shakes and stuff that's a wrong thing to do if you have cancer in my
opinion at the autoimmune course page on the website when I click on access to the course it takes me
to the detox course please check it we're okay dusted I'm gonna copy that and send that to dusted
different so I will put that forward to dusted and uh we'll get out and figure out
where the eyes act to the lip any other questions or what do you suggest to keep the lip moving
so we'll live the moving the lip moves by action of the muscles so you have to be contracting your muscles
so your lip system does not have a hunt it uses the muscle as it's important to squeeze the vessels
and squeezes the fluid up through the capillaries the lip vessels and then there's a check valve
every three four inches the lip system until it can't go backwards so once you contract your muscles
it sports it up through the system through the lip vessel and then it can't go backwards so that's
the time you contract your moving lip through the vessels how you help to move fluid out of the
extracellular spaces into the lip system is action of movement so just like the the person's
comment back here that they're doing different exercises trying to be very low impact type exercises
that's the thing to do you can do very light weights get some pi-potal weights or two-potal weights
and do something like that that would that's that's the right thing to do so Ellen who asked the
question about the autoimmune force page on the website so that's where you clicked on it
I tested it last year so we'll check that right I think that's right coffee is that one thing I look
forward to in the AM it allows me to handle a little bit of fasting how much is too much
well if you don't have those defects on the coffee genes I mean technically you can drink three
four cups of coffee a day now if you want to be really pure with intermittent fasting you can you
you can drink coffee and it's still be considered it it still be considered as fast as long as you don't
put anything in it so it's black coffee technically even the purists with intermittent fasting that's
still approved so I think you could have several cups of coffee a day I don't think that's a problem
is the difference between stem cells and tumor cells well it's matter of semantics stem cells have
yet to become tumor cells so if their cancer stem cells they're stem cells from a cancer that have
yet to become a tumor now my definition we talked about this a lot the tumor is old term
for a lesion something that's growing in your body now we don't use the word tumor as much without
using an adjective like it's a benign tumor or it's a metastatic tumor or that that means it's coming
from a cancerous tumor or if it's benign it means just a growth of cells but it's not something that's
overtaking other things and it's not something that will ever you know kill a person so
it's a matter of semantics have you heard about restore a product created by Evan
Evan Elliott to treat the mitochondria I had to look that up and I think I looked it up I think this
is something you were taking I did look that up I can't remember exactly everything that was
in it that you're asking if there's something in the problem I'd have to read on that uh
okay okay this is ultra mitel is that what it is?
Restore agreed it's all over a laxito all of lead extensive tumoric
and exploits have spirulina in bubobrolysis oh you're honest don't feel good this shakes I don't see
anything in there that raises a flag bill the only thing that I would say is when you get a product that
has that many ingredients you're not getting very much of anything so let's you drink in the whole bottle
if you when you have something it's you're not getting you know you could only get so much of
these things in the teaspoon so I mean you're not you're not getting a lot of everything okay that's
okay uh if lymph has been stagnant for a while five months lymph starts moving it is there anything
that should be done to support the body as the lymph starts to flow I have been feeling pretty
well you've got to be supporting the detox pathway so you've got to go back to the seven phases of
detox you've got to make sure that you're eliminating well if you're by needed you've got that your
gallbladder is not sluggish that's the biggest thing that you need to be concerned about if you're
detoxing you could end up with gallstones you want to support your gallbladder go back to the
seventh phase of detox of course if you want to get full detail about it but using hot packs and
casserole packs over your liver fall nutter will be really helpful this is where caught the
endomus are extremely helpful for somebody who's feeling really lucky because they're detoxing
to get you know everybody wants to get the lymph will we want to get the stuff out of the tissues
but you got to make sure that once you get it on tissues it's going to go back into the blood and
you got to make sure that it can get through the liver detox pathways and get through the gallbladder
and get into the colon and get into the toilet so the seven phases of detox are really important so
do take a little bit of time and review that I was just making sure coffee wasn't too estrogetic
for me to have several cups I put organic stevia I don't want to see any problem with that you
fermented dairy products and put it raw you know organic still have HGC it should be avoided that
is true yes you should still be avoided so just because you have a fermented dairy like a keeper does
not mean it still doesn't have growth hormones and like so yes it should be it should be a
void now if you're like a whole man I really love my yogurt you can buy coconut milk yogurt and
almond milk yogurt you're fine with that do we have to use homeopathic drugs for MRI too we don't
have to eat anything but we do have homeopathic drops for MRI but they're for gadolidium not for
radiation you don't have any radiation in MRI which you you're using MRI with a contrast you're
getting gadolidium which can build up in your system and even what MRI if you have a gadolidium
sensitivity could be a major problem for some people but if you do multiple MRIs you are
able to build up with gadolidium that's for the problem too so that's why we have the homeopathic
dropper for the MRI and that's why it's different for the MRI versus radiation
headscan, sutis, scan X right totally different so you can't take both and you're giving both
I have daily access to a beaver machine where this will be helpful to incorporate this so
what right how long how often so yeah beaver is a low-gouse PEMF but still low-gouse is
better than no-gouse so absolutely I would use it daily and you'd have to refer to their manual
about super familiar with the recommendations I know they recommend like like 30 minutes or
something pretty short term for it's just fine if you don't have any disease process but I mean
typically when we have people in the office we use a high-gouse PEMF and we do it our day at least and
so doing which is equivalent to probably doing two weeks worth of the beaver but still I'd still
use the beaver if you have access to it I use it doing it you know or as long as you can really
you know without so interrupting your life but I would do I would do it if I had it for sure
all right I think we'll call it a night thank you guys for participating I will say please if you
could get your questions in a or earlier I was scrambled and getting all the questions on the
on the zoom keto today I missed yours not to ask it again so the earlier if you get your questions
and I know your life is super busy too but that would be helpful to me because so I have to actually
copy and paste them and usually like you know if they don't get to read that would be so a
thank you all participating know that I'm praying for all you guys and if you do have questions
that you feel and you want personal answers to you can always call it schedule time that's me all right
love you all bye bye